the T party have given up on standing up
for uh British culture British values
they're all over the place on this and
it's only reform actually that have been
really strong amongst the top three or
four polling parties we've made it
absolutely crystal clear there should be
none of this uh gender questioning
allowing any social transitioning any
debate about this in schools up to the
age of 18 we think it's it's absurd I'm
going to campaign events up and down the
country parents and grandparents are
utterly fuming and Furious at what is
going along uh the uh the sort of the
hiding of information the third party
providers some of whom providing
material that is nothing short frankly
of revolting we've been Crystal Clear
we' ban the whole lot and it's the sort
of thing that actually you could do
within just a few days